[Music]
in contracts or important needed by that
good a small business owners upset after
an influencer allegedly accepted his
product without promoting it oh no it
was an expensive product um what someone
gave someone a product influencer didn't
actually promote it we kept it right
yeah and so they probably had to arrange
me like hey if I give this to you can
you please promote it but then there's
probably no contract so he got some
amateurish [ __ ] yeah so this story also
from the okay yes bridges he ended up
sending this chick named PG cake who's
an influencer does she make cakes or she
oh but builder I have no idea it's
either a baking Instagram or a fitness
instant why not she bakes cakes on her
takes me well what I what I do know is
that she's a youtuber and musician oh
she's not a booty builder I would have
been a great name for a baker or a booty
build a big booty violin player she the
thong that plays are violent they are
starting to sexualize classical music
yeah yeah she looks really hot she's
playing piano I like she has this really
dope apartment and like overlooking
Central Park Wow first she dresses in
like some really really nice are you
talking about the Russian girl the Asian
one Asian girl okay yeah I know the
Russian one with like black hair she was
like really short skirts yes your body
is amazing yeah the hair color changes
in my head okay [ __ ] the hair
so peih-gee cake she has 256 thousand
followers on Instagram so shavar kelly
who is a small business owner sent her a
personal as his PGP that's the
influences that
flannels pretty shoe except for this is
their conversation that's how it begins
so that's so the business
said hey would love to collab by sending
you one of our graphic tees and you post
a pic or vid of you wearing it and
shouting us out reply with your thoughts
and I can give you more information and
show you our tee designs and then he
sent a couple designs and then he said
would you be down and then this third
one the third third design and then he
said we also just added this in black
and pink she said yes I love that one
and he said perfect I'd love to send it
to you do you have an address I could
say she said her address
no she's done the address a couple of
dead pixels right there large chunks and
then the conversation continued with
what size should I order small please so
then I'm November
hey how about okay how about $0.02 oh
hey about to send out the shirts would
you mind sending me your insights please
also are there any terms and conditions
regarding promotion with you and so she
ends up sending the insights and then
she says hey what sort of terms and
conditions and those insights are from
today and then he says like for example
is there a certain schedule you have for
when you post or she didn't understand
what terms and conditions met oh my god
is that her saying it what's terms and
conditions okay for example is there a
certain schedule you have for when you
post or post tactics or do you promote
when the item arrives oh I just like to
promote once I take an ice pick I don't
like being pressurized
lol like if I'm gonna do it I'd rather
do it and make it good cuz I could take
a rush pic with no makeup or I can wait
till I'm all flicked up and take a
bangin pic yeah totally I get what you
mean that's perfect
can't wait parts your t-shirt should bro
ride within a couple of days okay dope
thank you and then he says um just
checking if you're still doing our promo
because I was sent up
on your bebop D pop and it's the t-shirt
so I guess D pop is a platform where you
can sell your used clothes and so she
ended up posting it on her sale about a
month later she posted it to make money
on it wow she was selling it for five
British pounds basically she's getting
pre murdered and reselling well like
promo merch that she's supposed to do a
little like collab with and she's like
selling it but she never promoted also
by the way and then um so this business
owner went to Twitter and like just
really oh and then well before that he
says you're posting on your IG story and
if you posted my t-shirt on D pop yet
you haven't replied honestly at this
point you're taking the piss so at 9
p.m. if you haven't updated me or even
given a reply I'm going public with this
this is the second promo situation where
you've done [ __ ] bro
I don't even add the promo what the pro
at this point yes so then that's when he
decided to post it on Twitter and then
he titled it a thread Paigey cakey the
fraud and then put all that there yes
she's just a kid that doesn't understand
[Music]
over a t-shirt too it's like such a
small thing for him I'm sure that it's
petty
he's also small they're both amateurs
just like [ __ ] around they don't know
what they're doing like for me if I'm
sending out promos and whatever like
it's just take it yeah it's take it if
you wear the music promote it do it cuz
it shouldn't cost him that much to send
out like one piece of product and stuff
like that like if you're sending it out
you kind of have to like Swiss or an
extent except that it's you know you
know how many other people just get free
product not [ __ ] stop you got to do
something different
here's pre free product and a couple
thousand dollars pre post it yeah be
more professional body on your end so
what he says is I just want influencers
to understand that as business owners
when we send our products out to them it
cost us it's never free so taking
advantage results in our personal loss
it's something that goes on a lot with
small business
[ __ ] amateur bro what the [ __ ] dude
you're a nickel and diming little
[ __ ] as business owners you
influences don't [ __ ] act high and
mighty what the [ __ ]
yeah you should factor that into your
like business and marketing you know
that's what [ __ ] it oh my god in
America those text messages could be
used as a Content that's a contract oh
really yeah I've seen them actually cuz
actually did a contract recently in one
of them type message as a form of
communication oh yeah with emails and
all SS it can be a contract go ahead an
agreement right so technically I get
where he's coming from
because she made an agreement yeah I
think principal wise she did [ __ ] up
yeah she said yeah I'll promote it
you don't go taking somebody's merch and
then just don't do not promote it and go
go around and sell it and make money off
of it that only thought for five pounds
knows that is a weed but also as
business owners we understand who we're
dealing with you're not dealing I mean
an influencer it's it's a huge range you
could go from multi-millionaire down to
like someone who just started in their
bedroom there's a huge range
you can't group them all into one and
then you can it's just it's just so
stupid to go like you got a gauge who
you're working with obviously if someone
doesn't understand what terms and
conditions is why do you expect them to
do business properly that's so [ __ ]
stupid dude that it just blows my mind I
don't know it annoys me because we were
from both worlds right like we owned
brands and and we do both and we've done
brand deals and and and but when it
comes to like there's this there's this
rent that people have of influencers as
as one thing and they get a bad rep
because like that whole spectrum is
amateur all the way up until like
extremely professional
multi-millionaires yeah yeah Kim
Kardashian is a influencer right she
does sponsors and promos yeah so it's
like man you but it's also an amateur
thought to not understand who you're
working with as a business owner and I'm
sure when you guys send out gift boxes
and all that
you're not hounding down everybody like
hey where's your [ __ ] barbell promo
and like threatening to like like
dragging on Twitter dude you just send
it out and just knowing that this person
wearing it it might be in a picture one
day they might not patent tag you but
the word is being spread and the brand
is being spread and you go for the long
term you don't nickel and dime and [ __ ]
like that I've had a lot of brands that
do that it's like I want to send you
some stuff cool how did you like it
honest opinion it wasn't that great
whatever no but we gave you free [ __ ]
well [ __ ] you what are gonna do about it
you want it free promo you [ __ ] cheap
ass [ __ ] or you could put your real
thoughts on oh this just sucks don't
everybody yeah I want to do sometimes
it's all [ __ ] go up and be like this
[ __ ] sucks [ __ ] this company yeah so
some people responded to this like for
example one said if it's you that wants
her action then why are you asking about
terms and conditions it's your business
and your responsibility to provide terms
and conditions the whole expose thing is
incredibly unprofessional and you should
stay away from that [ __ ] if you respect
your biz ya like him coming out with
that whole I'm as a business owner you
unprofessional insta influencers I'm
trying to oust you [ __ ] you man you're a
amateur as business owner [ __ ] nickel
and diming for shipping dude how much is
that [ __ ] t-shirt you made it for
like seven dollars if you're not an
idiot and then you ship it out for how
much 10 bucks you're bitching about 17
[ __ ] dollars Bob you guys what I'm
saying I think if this entire business
is gonna fall apart from 117 dollar loss
yeah dude your margins [ __ ] suck
thinner you're not making any sales ego
[ __ ] that flus prides hurt yeah because
like you girls said no just yeah
shut the [ __ ] up you're trying to get
cheap Pro like [ __ ] promotion oh my
god I hate these spot faces yes another
tweet said I know your pain but it's
part of the business you're in I've had
this happen several times just take the
El and don't use that person again that
that and that's the key thing just don't
use that person again I have the same
thing with a book funnels where you sin
you know books or reviewers and they get
it for free and exchange for a review if
they don't give you a review you don't
go like hey what I gave you a free book
give me
that you know the feedback is worse on
your part get a review because I maybe I
just didn't like it like you should from
or even that too it's just that if you
don't in there supposed to leave naked
video honors for you no matter what
doesn't matter what it is but it's just
like just don't use that person again
this easy as that it's just like take
them off your list you don't send them
any more free [ __ ] and then testing in
there is relationship how long does it
take to like how long do you give
someone to review your book usually you
should do about three months you should
it be about three months typically it's
gonna be a long blow it should be but it
should be like around three months three
to one month to three months but nothing
shorter than a month people should be
able to finish the book in a day yeah I
mean that's usually the case you know
days a week those are what the reviewer
you want to give it to them early
because they might a lot of books in
there oh like that's their job that's a
job I'll eat some books man this is a
funny space we're living in though
because anybody can be an influencer
business owner now so yeah another
training yes
amateurs [ __ ] with amateurs thinking
that they're professionals it's like
shut the [ __ ] up dude it's kind of
entertaining what it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]